welcome to another study with me video
looking through some quantum mechanics
and looking at the mathematical
foundations for describing ideas and
quantum physics so if you're following
along on the brilliant website I'm going
to be working through part of the
collapsing States module now we've been
dealing with a lot of probabilities so
far in this course and we've been making
a mathematical framework that you might
recognize here this is a way of
representing a probability of observing
an outcome a honuts from an inner
product or a bra ket notation now one
thing to know and keep in mind is that
you know through all of this mathematics
it's still impossible to know exactly
what state is going to result from say
an experiment these probabilities here
that we can write are just the
probability observe of observing each
outcome but we never know exactly what
is going to happen and this I guess was
a bit of a disturbing part of quantum
mechanics especially in the early days
and I think even Einstein had a quote
saying God does not play dice when he
initially rejected this idea that
quantum mechanics comes down to
probabilities and that there is an
inherent randomness to reality but as I
understand it and I think the way that
you know most people in quantum
mechanics agree on is that there is this
inherent randomness or probability to
quantum events so it's a little bit
unsettling but what I'm going to talk
about in this video sort of centers
around the idea of what is going on
during measurement because this all
sounds a little bit strange so let's
keep reading now this again is the
experiment that I've looked at in a few
of the previous videos it's the
stern-gerlach experiment you take a
unknown kit and so this is a state but
we don't know anything about it we put
it through this analyzer which in the Z
direction that's the straight
up-and-down direction here it
separates it out into being either spin
up or spin down these are also states
described by the kit notation now as a
bit of a reminder our unknown kit or
sigh which is like our wave function
that we input can be written as a linear
combination some a amount of the spin up
state and some B amount of the spin down
state this is called the s Z basis
because we'll Ziya digest our basis
vectors in the up down you know
direction these a and B values are
scalars so I guess there are numbers and
they are the probability amplitudes of
being spin up or spin down so you could
also write a and B like this where a is
the inner product between spin up and
out unknown state this kind of makes
sense because the inner product remember
is an amount of overlap so the
probability of being you know how much
you ask then up is the overlap between
spin up and your unknown input you know
just keep in mind that that's how you
can write these a and B amplitudes and
let's keep going so this line here is
just rewriting what we had on the
previous page but instead of writing a
and B here they've replaced a and B with
the inner product version or the inner
product notation so yet this whole line
here is scalars times by state kits in
this case a times spin up and B times
spin down now a scaler is like a number
you're probably familiar with it you can
change the order of multiplication so it
doesn't matter which order you do
multiplication and if you dealing with a
scalar value so we can actually move
these inner products you know behind
this state kit and actually what we get
when we do that is this next line down
here
where they've also taken the unknown
state kit out of the brackets because
it's common to both terms this allows us
to get a look at these terms and here a
double up arrow or a double down arrow
and these terms are called outer
products they are multiplied in the
opposite order of the inner products so
you might recognize that they look a bit
funny compared to what we're used to
dealing with which is the inner product
now these outer products can be quite
useful and in fact if you have the sum
of outer products acting on a kit it
returns the exact same kit unchanged
that's if you have the sum of all the
outer products over your basis well here
we're representing I to just be like a
placeholder and our basis in this case
is an up arrow and a down arrow so if we
have up arrow up arrow times the kit +
down arrow down arrow times the kit we
just end up with the kit itself we've
summed over our entire basis and we get
the same kit out at the end unchanged
the reason that we get the same kit out
unchanged is because multiplying by the
sum of the outer products over the whole
basis is like multiplying by the
identity or multiplying by one anything
times one will just give you that thing
you started with now this might seem a
little bit pointless but it can come in
handy because applying a sum of outer
products is a way of expressing any
state as a sum of the contributions of
each basis kit so it's a way of writing
out the state in terms of everything
that makes it up and then you might see
that that comes in useful later all
right so we have a question here
basically about determining the form of
an outer product like what actually is
this outer product what do these
products yield when multiplied by an
unknown state sigh so that's when we
just multiply one outer product by the
unknown state and not summing over the
higher basis what do we have what do we
get if we just x say up up by our
unknown state well what happens is they
produce their own eigenstate when they
are used on any state now I don't think
we've spoken about what an eigenstate is
but we can have a look at it here it's
basically it returns a scalar value it
returns some multiple of itself when an
outer product for a particular state say
spin up acts on an unknown state sigh it
produces its own state kit with a scalar
factor okay so if you were to do the
outer product of spin up spin up on side
you would get out the spin up state kit
with some scalar factor a so we can work
through this a little bit more solely we
started with our familiar unknown state
sigh which is made up of a amount of
spin up and B amount of spin down we
applied the outer product of spin up to
it and this line here is just rewriting
this but in a just rearranging it we've
taken what was out in the front and put
it down the back so we've taken that kit
that's hanging out the front we've put
it behind and it gives us an inner
product times a kit which we recognize
from before as being a times the kit
because we know that this inner product
here is equal to a that was something
that we just went over
alright so applying an outer product to
something so an unknown state actually
makes it end up in a known state we
we've gone from being in an unknown
state to being in some multiple of spin
up so we've actually you know change the
state that this quantum particle is in
so this might be summarized on the next
page a little bit yeah it's a
mathematical tool that mimics the effect
we first observed in Chapter one so
that's what I spoke about in the last
video and that is that a measurement
Candice
the system and collapse the state
quantum measurements cannot be made
without disturbing the state except in
the case where an input state as the
same as the output state that's like if
you're measuring something twice and you
already know what it is you're not going
to change it there this is a radical
departure from classical machines the
collapse of a quantum state also makes
quantum mechanics irreversible again
this is in stark contrast to classical
mechanics once an input state sy is
observed and states and up then the
output state is no longer sy but has
been collapsed and to spin up in effect
the analyzer prepares that state and
removes the possibility of any other
state being observed this collapse is
equivalent to an application of the
outer product or projection spin up spin
up for the Upstate so once a neutron
emerges from the up channel it's not in
the state sy anymore it's now in this
projection or outer product x sy which
we know is a times spin up it's in a
different state we can use this new
knowledge of defining probabilities to
look back at one of the experiments
we've discussed in a previous video
that's the one where we take a input
Neutron which we know to be spin up we
put it through an X analyzer resistor
and Gaelic analyzer to measure it as
either spin left or spin right and then
we again measure its the Z Direction
spin so either spin up or spin down so
we can work out that the probability of
being on this yellow path would be 1/4
there's 50-50 chance here and another
50-50 chance here
so to go all the way along the yellow
path would be 1/4 and that's the way
that we would write it out likewise for
the pink path it would be 1/4 and you
know with classical probabilities that
would be like this we would say ok
there's a quarter or a Probert
quarter of a probability being yellow
quarter probability being pink so if we
sum both of those paths 1/4 plus 1/4
equals 1/2 and we would expect in this
final experiment for 1/2 of the neutrons
to come out span up from this output
place here if you've seen the previous
video of mine in the series and remember
it that is actually not what we see we
don't see a 50/50 chance here at this
final analyser
instead we see a hundred percent of the
neutrons coming out the end as spin up
so there was something that happened
along the way where the memory of it
being spin up was retained all the way
from the start even though we'd had this
intermediate step which usually would
completely reset the memory of any of
the particles because X and Z are
orthogonal to each other we would have
expected this to completely reset and
any information about the spin of the
particles and we wouldn't have expected
one that had initially been spin up to
remain spin up all the way through so
there's something going on here
brilliance is what is wrong with our
approach the answer is that this
combined channel of spin lifts and right
neutrons can't be treated as just a mix
of different neutrons but instead they
are a superposition of spin lift and
spin right so we need a mathematical way
to represent this state which is a
superposition of I guess two different
options and when we do that and I'm
going to work through that in the next
video it will kind of wrap up this
little section we've been going through
and hopefully our probabilities will
give us that this is a hundred percent
spin up at the end instead of what we're
currently working with is that we're
getting that it's only a half so I'm
looking forward to doing that in the
next video and finally having a
mathematical framework that's consistent
with all the experiments that we've seen
and all the results that we've seen
because currently this classical way of
looking at probabilities doesn't work
for us we need something
little bit more I'm looking forward to
seeing you in that next video I think it
will probably be the last one in this
math for quantum physics series and
don't forget that if you do want to work
through these courses yourself and a lot
more in depth and I can do it with you
then you can go to brilliant org slash
Tibby's and sign up for free the first
200 of my viewers that use that link can
also get 20% off a premium and your
subscription and I think you'd really
enjoy it if you want to go a bit more in
depth than what I've been able to do
here but see you next time and keep your
questions coming in about this stuff I
think that some of my maths has been
improving along the way so I hope yours
has been to see it in
[Music]